do you think there will ever be a boy group
who tries to mainly obtain a male demographic?
saw this on reddit
when I first got into K Pop.
this was something that I questioned as well.
but let me tell you why this will never ever
ever happen.
one it's pointless.
the majority of K pop consumers are female.
right, and they are attracted to K pop because of
how K pop markets itself.
and that's a whole conversation for another video.
but just know
the market for K pop is damn near all female.
so from a financial standpoint
it wouldn't make sense for a boy group to try and
reach out to guys
when guys aren't attached to this thing like girls are.
now that's not to say there aren't any guys that
stand boy groups.
there aren't any guys that you know
like bro look at me bro.
I got like 4 one US albums and 2 txt albums.
I got txt posters,
nct posters.
like I watch a lot of boy group content as well.
I'm someone who is very open minded to this stuff
and actually enjoy this stuff,
but a lot of guys out there are just not the same way.
and if there is a guy out there who is a K Pop Stan,
it is more than likely that he is a girl group stand.
he will probably listen to a lot of boy group songs,
but he's going to be
a lot more attached to the girl groups.
probably for the same reason
a lot of girls are attached to boy groups
rather than girl groups.
although these times are changing,
as we've seen.
number 2. uh,
this can kind of come off as disrespectful,
depending on who you're asking.
this kind of insinuates that something needs male
validation for it to truly be popular
or for it to truly be successful,
which just isn't true.
look at Twice,
for example.
they started off with a huge male following,
but as soon as
they got the girls to hop over on their side,
they skyrocketed.
I think boy groups should
stick to doing what they're doing right,
because it works.
a lot of the new GU.
boy groups, right,
the ones that come from very small companies,
can still make it very easily,
make a living out of this
very easily
because of those female audiences.
unfortunately,
it is a little more difficult for girl groups
around that level as well.
but for the guys,
yeah. lastly,
how would this even look like
if rap heavy groups like Stray Kids
or BTS can't pull in male stands,
if groups like Treasure can't pull in male stands, then.
then it's just kind of pointless,
because those guys is music.
it's not necessarily like,
oh, look at me, I'm so hot,
I'm so cute, look at me.
while they do have songs like that,
let's be honest,
they have music that do
cover certain topics
that do cover serious things as well.
but topics like,
I guess, men's mental health,
being a single father,
stuff like that,
if that's what you mean.
when somebody says,
a boy group reaching out for a male demographic,
you're not gonna find that in K pop.